award-winning food over the top crazy
shakes and killer craft beers a pop and
playlist we are so excited to have
stephen parker the corporate executive
chef of black tap crafted burgers and
beer at the venetian with us
thank you so much i was just telling you
i love this place their shakes are
incredible we'll talk a little bit about
that in just a second yeah of course
well let's talk about what you're really
known for and that's your burgers so
yeah people come for the shakes they
stay for the food so our you know most
exciting burger we have on the menu
right now is our wago steakhouse burger
so it's our award-winning burger last
year 2021 um burger bash champions in
new york it's a great burger we're just
gonna go through how we made it let's
make this okay so wagyu that is like a
premium top of the lime meat right it's
great we get it from australia it's
marbled it's really delicious it has all
the juices you want i like to order
medium rare myself okay we cooked it
medium today our medium is nice and pink
juicy all the way through we baste it
with some a1 steak sauce
man i hope i make it as good as you guys
yeah literally one a little eight one
okay and then we have our our applewood
smoked bacon so take two pieces pieces
yeah take two pieces shingle it on there
crisscross oh crisscross yeah so that
way you get a butt when you eat it every
last piece of butt you get you always
want the bacon yeah so then we're going
to take that top bun take a little
roasted garlic now just spread it all
along coast to coast we call it coastal
coast coast east to west right
everywhere in between no
bun will be left uncovered yeah there
you go then put it right there open
always open and then top it off with
crispy onions as much as you want i love
the crispy onions
so we're putting lots and then you want
to put a little more a1 on there there
you go delish would you hire me
i mean you are a pretty good sous chef
you're pretty great we're going to do
two handfuls of fries okay so your nice
amount of golden french fries and look
at her burger i need that thing the
wahoo burger to perfection i'm not
trying to brag or anything but we eat
this and we are going to eat this but
after that is dessert and let's talk
about some of the great the shakes like
you said you're known for the shakes
let's talk about these so we're known
for shake so this month in las vegas at
the venetian we're doing our pride shake
in collaboration with the donut bar lv
and we're donating a dollar from every
shake we sell to the pride tree so we're
really happy doing a collab with someone
from las vegas like the donut bar it's a
great shake it's ombre of three
different colors we coat the rim in
nerds it's beautiful twisty pop rainbow
stick and there you go a little more
nerds on top delicious oh my gosh like
the colors i don't know if they're
coming across on television but they're
just so vibrant and this one you got my
attention on this because this is
perfect for summer yeah for summer so
for june we're doing a myers lemon
blueberry shake it's topped off a little
buttery cake topping on top and some
whipped cream it's really great can i
taste this one you could taste that a
little lemon a little blueberry and you
get a little butter i'm gonna make a
mess here that's good though that's the
fun part of blacktop is making that mess
that's a part of it oh my gosh that is
so good wow okay you can finish this
interview what else do you have and then
we have this canal chop salad right here
so that's our canal chop style for the
month of june it's a really healthy
yummy salad with a lot of asian
ingredients it has that ube plum
vinaigrette stopped off with some crispy
noodles and cilantro some sesame seeds
it's a really great salad so if you go
in and you get a nice salad then you
won't feel as guilty finishing off with
one of these milkshakes right yes you
definitely got to check it out this this
is incredible we've got a burger to get
to we've got you did a great job you
really did a great job thank you very
much we are going to tell everyone how
to get to blacktap you guys are at the
venetian where are you located
right on the casino floor right by the
sportsbook okay go check them out so
good jillian sending it over to you